No  you  it is - what have you to say for  yourself  God's favor action not kill Jesus this  council  you rule over nothing  Atlantis is in ruin nothing can change  that  everything must burn only then can send  a Jew again madness for your Treasury  using the knowledge of the Scot unleash  our armies against us expel you forever  from the secret order of the three  condemn you to shame in the frozen limbo  of eternity you cannot be stopped  the wheels of captain already ashes  do they will find you bastard  it was you you were the queen of antis  once and thus kion holds its history it  holds far more than that all the  knowledge of the Ancients things none of  you could even comprehend what is the  7th age  how far are you willing to go to find  out Lara  not far enough  I'm afraid killer quickly we have work  to do I'm gonna join this you hot  yeah  you